[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de Parlement Hebdo nous sommes
ensemble pour 26 minutes pour revoir le
meilleur de l'actu politique et
parlementaire de la semaine avec notre
invité et notre invité cette semaine
c'est Louis carvé bonjour bonjour vous
êtes sénateur centriste de la Haute
Savoie et vice-président du Sénat et
bien on va revoir avec vous la Une de
cette semaine après une attente
interminable le gouverne est désormais
complet principal changement Nicole Bou
remplace Amélie oua Castera à
l'éducation nationale le refus de
François Barou d'entré au gouvernement a
provoqué un début de crise dans la
majorité le Parlement veut mieux
protéger les élus l'Assemblée nationale
a voté une proposition de loi d'origine
sénatoriale elle prévoit un durcissement
des sanctions envers les agresseurs
d'élus et puis on reparle de la loi
immigration les sénateurs centristes et
les républicains déposent chacun un
texte pour remettre sur la table
certaines mesures qui avaient été
retoquées par le Conseil
constitutionnel après un mois d'attente
on connaît enfin la composition complète
du gouvernement revue d'effectif avec
Mathias SZ l'heure des ajustements a
sonné un mois après sa nomination
Gabriel Atal a étaufé son exécutif au
premier rang deux ministres de plein
exercice complètent l'équipe
gouvernementale pour porter son nombre à
16 membres Nicole Bouet ancienne garde
d'essau jusqu'en 2020 dlest Amélie oua
Castera de l'éducation nationale elle
conserve les sports et les Jos Stanislas
Guerini macroniste de la première heure
retrouve quant à lui un mois plus tard
son portefeuille de la transformation et
de la fonction publique ce jeudi c'est
principalement le casting des ministres
délégués et secrétaire d'État qui
étaient attendu là encore peu de
changement Roland lescur Olivia Grégoire
et Thomas kaznav retrouvent leur
fonction passée tout comme Dominique
fort chargé des collectivités
territoriales Hervé Berville à la mer ou
Sabrina Agresti rouba chargé de la ville
et de la citoyenneté parmi les nouveaux
visages Frédéric Valtou député horizon
viendra prêter main forte à Catherine
Vautrin au ministère de la Santé
Guillaume casbarian député Renaissance
récupère le logement enfin Marina
Ferrari député MoDem de Savoie sera en
charge du numérique malgré sa colère
froide François Baayou conserve donc
quatre marocains ministériels
un exécutif de 35 membres Premier
ministre compris soit 7 de moins que
dans la dernière équipe borne l' carv on
a attendu un mois pour avoir la
composition complète de ce gouvernement
pas d'énormes changement au final tout
ça pour ça c'est un peu la réaction
qu'on peut avoir en en découvrant ce
nouveau gouvernement qui à part des
ajustements marginaux et puis des
changements de portefeuille pour un
certain nombre de ministres on voit
arriver quelques personnalités nouvelles
mais effectivement avoir pris un mois et
quelque part avoir gâché le
début du mandat de de Gabriel Atal c'est
un peu dommage parce que le gouvernement
a mis du temps à se à être
complet Premier ministre a pris du temps
pour faire son discours politique
général dans l'intervalle il y a eu
cette question de la grande conférence
du président de la République ce
feuilletonnage du du du mois de janvier
on en sort avec avec un peu
d'interrogation quand même parce que le
pays N n'a pas vraiment besoin de ça
pays a plutôt besoin d'une ligne claire
de d'un d'un rythme et ce rythme ben le
mois de janvier n'a pas été tout à fait
à la hauteur et y compris d'ailleurs sur
les travaux parlementaires qui est quand
même un sujet qui nous qui nous qui nous
intéresse ici c'est c'est une
interrogation pour nous alors Nicole
Boubé c'est l'un des principaux
changement devient ministre de
l'éducation nationale elle était garde
des saut dans le premier quinquenna
d'Emmanuel Macron voilà ce que dit Bruno
retaillot patron font des sénateurs LR
d'elle elle est-elle une des ministres
la justice les plus laxistes de la 5e
République est-ce que pour vous c'est le
bon profil Nicole Boué pour incarner
l'autorité à l'école et ben je sais pas
h alors évidemment on va pouvoir
ressortir tout un tas de déclarations de
Madame Boubet
sur tout un tas de sujets qui sont
notamment en lien avec l'école ce qui
est certain c'est que l'éducation
nationale ne peut pas se réformer contre
les enseignants et que la situation qui
était celle entre madame cterra et ses
déclarations malheureuses de tout début
de de fonction et le le corps enseignant
faisait que la situation était
inextricable donc le gouvernement est
est maintenant composé avec madame
beloubet qui a été un moment donné garde
des saut j'en garde pas un
souvenir extraordinaire parce qu' il y a
une question d'incarnation à un moment
que là c'était pour apaiser oui mais
enfin apaiser ser à une chose mais c'est
quand même l'école est quand même le
sujet des sujet surtout que Gabriel
Attal veut un retour de l'autorité à
l'école sûr bien sûr d'autant plus que
le premier ministre qui est resté 6 mois
donc c'est Nicole Boué qui devra bah si
vous voulez vous pouvez apaiser mais il
faut quand même réformer et vous vous
devez réformer avec les enseignants et
donc je je m'interroge et donc je pense
que Madame bouber aura des des preuves à
nous apporter de sa capacité justement à
à à recréer de la confiance d'une part
et à porter les réformes dont l'école
française a besoin vous parliez de ces
anciennes déclarations à propos de
l'affaire Mila donc c'est cette lycéenne
qui avait été menacé de mort pour avoir
critiqué l'islam et bien Nicole Boué
avait déclaré je cite que l'insulte à la
religion était une atteinte à la liberté
de conscience cette déclaration avait
fait à l'époque un tolé est-ce que sa sa
nomination c'est un mauvais signal
envoyé euh par rapport à à l'objectif de
la lutte pour la laïcité et contre le
harcèlement à l'école en tout cas il
faudra que Madame Belouet dans les
premiers jours ou les premières semaines
de son nouveau ministère clarifie sa
position sur des sujets sur lesquels la
question de l'autorité républicaine à
l'école publ est une question absolument
fondamentale non pas seulement pour
l'opinion publique mais pour les élèves
parce que on fabrique dans notre école
des citoyens responsables et que la
manière dont on transmet un certain
nombre de principes et de valeurs à
l'école républicaine est absolument
fondamental donc et je pense que
là-dessus le briefing du Premier
ministre sera assez clair vis-à-vis de
sa ministre alors le portefeuille de
l'éducation nationale a donc été retiré
de du périmètre d'Amélie oua casterra
qui reste en revanche ministre des
Sports est-ce que le gouvernement pour
vous a cédé à la pression des syndicats
on en parlait tout à l'heure c'est pas
tellement la
question le le quand vous êtes ministre
de l'éducation nationale c'est-à-dire
vous êtes ministre de l'écoole publique
et laïque vous devez avoir une posture
une incarnation qui fait que vous êtes
le chef ou la chef en l'occurrence d'une
très grande administration française et
très très grande très noble très
ancienne qui porte un certain nombre de
de choses et ces réflexions sur je mets
pas sur les justifications pour
lesquelles vous avez pas mis vos enfants
dans l'école publique mais vous les avez
mis dans une école catholique sous
contrat par
ailleurs ça ça ça crée du du
trouble la la question je suis bien
placé pour le savoir mais la question de
la scolarisation de vos enfants c'est un
choix individuel personnel non
contestable là c'est pas ça qui mais
c'est pas ça le sujet le sujet c'est que
c'est le message envoyé et ça n'était
pas rattrapable alors il y a il y a les
syndicats qu'on on évidemment qui ont
utilisé cette situation mais je pense
que la situation dans laquelle Amélie ou
Castera était était inextricable pour le
pour le pour le gouvernement et c'était
plutôt sain de faire un changement
maintenant à Madame Bouet prouvver
qu'elle était la bonne personne alors il
y en a un qui n'entre pas au
gouvernement qui a refusé entré c'est
François Baayou à cause d'un désaccord
profond autour du ministère de
l'Éducation nationale on va l'écouter
j'étais persuadé qu'on peut redresser
l'éducation nationale en peu d'années
mais que ça demande un choix politique
qui est de faire ça avec les enseignants
et les autres parties prenantes de
l'école pardon mais c'est pas le cas de
la personne qui sera nommé non mais vous
vous voyez bien on est on est sur un
fond
de
de une musique de fond qui est au fond
les enseignants travaillent pas assez
ALV ce cas François baayrou c'est une
affaire personnelle d'un poids lourd de
la majorité qui n'a pas eu le poste qu'
l'escontait ou c'est le signe d'une
crise plus profonde au sein de la
majorité présidentielle moi ce qui se
passe dans le bureau du président de la
République avec François Baayou ou avec
ou dans le bureau de Gabriel avec
François Baou m'intéresse assez peu en
revanche quand François Baou prend la
parole moi qui suis de cette famille
centr triste sans être d'ailleurs dans
le par de François baayerou quand
François baayerou prend la parole je
l'écoute toujours parce que il a souvent
une forme de prémonition ou une forme de
diagnostique sur le mal français sur ce
qui se passe dans la société française
qui moi me fait toujours réfléchir je
suis pas toujours d'accord avec lui mais
c'est une des très grandes figures de la
vie politique française
incontestablement et ce qu'il exprime y
compris dans ce moment-là de notre vie
politique on ferait mieux de l'écouter
sans caricaturer ce qui a à dire à titre
personnel évidemment le sujet de ça son
entrée au gouvernement interroge il ne
va pas rentrer donc ça interroge
d'autant plus mais ce qu'il dit de la
société française ce qu'il dit de
l'école française on on ferait bien et
je pense que le président la République
et Premier ministre ferait bien de
l'entendre parce que les élections
présidentielles sont dans 3 ans et demi
justement et que et oui mais et que ça
va être long hein donc c'est important
d'entendre cela mais François Baayou
candidat pour 2027 ça vous paraîtrait
être un le bon candidat même pour le
centre vous êtes centriste j'en sais
rien c'est beaucoup trop tôt pour le
dire vous savez très bien que mais
pourquoi pas non mais en tout cas
François baayerou a joué j'ai fait trois
campagnes présidentielles de François
Baayou donc je je sais très bien de quoi
je parle François baayerou a joué un
rôle politique important y compris pour
faciliter l'élection et la réélection du
président de la République donc il aura
sa voitat on je dirais même qu'on l'aime
ou qu'on l'aime pas c'est pas le sujet
c'est que en fait il est une une
personnalité incontournable je ne sais
pas si il décidera d'être candidat ou
pas on verra bien les choses en
l'occurrence environ un an avant
l'élection présidentielle donc mais dans
la période qui interméd bien bien
évidemment qu'il faut l'écouter il a
raison quand il parle d'une déconnexion
entre les élites l'État et la base le
peuple français les territoires mais
nous la vivons tous les jours
c'est-à-dire que les l'organisation des
institutions françaises fait que elle
elle elle conduisent au risque que de de
la rupture de de de de cette coupure
qu'il y a entre le pays réel et et ses
élus et ça si vous si vous n en avez pas
conscience et si vous n'avez ne faites
pas un effort sur vous-même je parle de
moi là dans dans dans l'exercice de
votre mandat et bien vous vous coupez
complètement de la réalité des Français
et ça François Baayou l'a dit très bien
sur les ondes de vos conf de France Info
et et donc c'était important de l'avoir
de de l'avoir en tête moi je me moi en
tout cas je le garde en tête en tout cas
si on se projette sur l'agenda
parlementaire LV il n'y a pas encore de
texte très important à l'ordre du jour
du Parlement or Gabriel hatal a dit
qu'il voulait aller vite avoir une
politique efficace avec des résultats
rapides est-ce que vous craignez qu'il
contourne le Parlement il aura pas le
choix parce que vous savez dans un pays
comme le nôtre on a une constitution et
puis on a des parlementaires on a un
président du Sénat par exemple auprès
duquel je travaille qui va euh regarder
ça avec beaucoup d'attention et et et de
vigilance donc euh je vis vous donner un
exemple quand vous faites des réunions
dans les départements où vous avez les
préfets qui vont rencontrer les
agriculteurs pour parler de
l'assouplissement desnmes et que vous
faites ces réunions le mercredi pour que
les parlementaires ne viennent pas et
ben on commence mal
donc alors que un certain nombre
d'ailleurs de ces assouplissements
passeront nécessairement par par la loi
forcément donc le Parlement est
incontournable et on ne se laissera pas
contourner ça c'est sûr ni effacer parce
que le risque c'est pas tellement le
contournement le risque c'est l'E le
risque c'est le dialogue direct entre
l'exécutif et le pays et en disant le
Parlement la majorité présidentielle n'a
pas la majorité à l'Assemblée nationale
et elle n'a pas la majorité au Sénat
donc faudra bien à un moment donné
discuter avec les formations politiques
avec les groupes politiques du Parlement
à l'Assemblée au Sénat et ça ce sera une
épreuve de vérité en tout cas Gabriel a
pris un certain nombre d'engagement
devant la Conférence des présidents à
l'Assemblée et au Sénat et moi je ne
crois que ce que j'entends donc quels
engagements des engagements justement de
de travail avec de non pas de
construction mais de construction des
textes avec les parlementaires
permettant aux parlementaires notamment
quand ils sont ou qu'ils ont été
rapporteurs d'apporter un certain nombre
de propositions le gouvernement écrit le
texte c'est sa responsabilité et ensuite
c'est le Parlement qui le modifie et qui
vote la loi un mot rapidement sur quand
même un texte symbolique qui lui est à
l'ordre du jour du Parlement c'est
l'introduction du droit à l'IVG en tout
cas de la liberté garantie de recourir à
l'IVG à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse introduction dans la
Constitution ça a été voté à l'Assemblée
nationale débat fin février au Sénat
avec l'issue du vote qui est incertaine
vous lis carvé vous êtes plutôt contre
est-ce qu'il n'y a pas un risque pour la
majorité de droite et du centre du Sénat
si elle rejette cette réforme et bien
d'apparaître comme rétrograde si on
place le débat euh un débat aussi
important sur un plan euh aussi
réducteur que la question de de l'aire
du temps alors on est à côté de
l'exercice c'est l'actualité américaine
qui nous fait euh légiférer sur ce sujet
et c'est le fait que la Cour suprême
américaine est décidé il y a près de 50
ans de rendre l'interromption V de
grossesse fédérale et de revenir sur
cette décision très récemment
mettre cette rédaction dans la
Constitution c'est donner des pouvoirs
au Conseil constitutionnel qui sont
considérables or le Conseil
constitutionnel on l'a vu sur le texte
sur l'immigration et renforcé depuis
2008 avec la question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité pour ma part et dans
la mesure d'ailleurs où il n'existe pas
dans le texte de protection de la clause
de conscience des professionnels de
santé sur la question de de de
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
pour ma part je ne voterai pas le fait
de
transférer l'appréciation au Conseil
constitutionnel c'est ça dont vos
téléspectateurs doivent être conscients
les membres du Conseil constitutionnel
ne sont pas élus ils sont nommés par les
hautes autorités de l'État le le le
président de la République et les
présidents de chambre on suivra ce débat
au Sénat euh fin février à la fin du
mois jusqu'à 7 ans d'emprisonnement et
100000 € d'amende contre les auteurs de
violence envers les élus les députés ont
ont adopté une proposition de loi venue
du Sénat pour renforcer la sécurité des
élus notamment des maire euh explication
de texte avec Elsa
mondingava l'objectif est simple mieux
protéger les élus contre les violences
l'élu local et le maire en particulier
est àorté d'embrassade à porté
d'engueelade mais il ne doit pas être
apporté de BAFF d'insultte de
diffamation les agressions contre les
élus sont en augmentation plus 15 %
entre 2022 et 2023 si chaque agression
est individuellement insupportable la
croissance de leur nombre rend le
phénomène absolument
intolérable
2265 agressions d'élu en
en 2023 la proposition de loi vise à
aligner le régime des sanctions en cas
de violence contre les élus locaux sur
celui des personnes dépositair de
l'autorité publique comme les policiers
autre avancée l'octroi automatique de la
protection fonctionnelle au Mair et aux
élus municipaux avec un mandat exécutif
en cas d'agression ou d'injure une
disposition a fait polémique le passage
de 3 mois à 1 an des délaiis de
prescription en cas d'injure et de
diffamation contre un élu ou un candidat
certains ont exprimé leur craintes pour
la liberté de la presse il y a une
disposition qui nous enquiète
particulièrement et qui inquiète aussi
les journalistes c'est effectivement le
délai de prescription qui a été posé et
qui nous passe un réel problème après le
Sénat la proposition de loi a été
largement adoptée à l'Assemblée une
autre réforme celle du statut de l'élu
local est prévue dans les prochains mois
scrutin votre les agressions contre les
élus dont vous êtes sont en hausse plus
de 2200 agressions encore en 2022 est-ce
que pour vous cette loi va permettre
d'arrêter ces violences en tout cas elle
y contribuera euh en tout cas elle
contribuera parce que ses agressions sur
les élus j'en ai moi-même été l'objet
euh quand j'étais maire elles sont
insupport menace de mort protection par
les gendarmes pendant 3 semaines
interpellation de de de la personne
personne condamné à un an de prison et
cetera oui oui non non mais ça existe
vraiment moi je l'ai je l'ai vu en vrai
que vous avez en France un certain
nombre d'élus qui vivent sous les
menaces et qui vivent sous les insultes
et qui vivent parfois sous les
agressions physiques donc cette question
là c'est une question si vous voulez
de de possibilité pour la République de
fonctionner normalement et cet
ensauvagement de notre société
elle se révèle aussi dans euh ces
relations qu'il y a entre certains de
nos concitoyens et les élus alors il y a
la loi la loi pénale notamment qui doit
être renforcée ça c'est très bien il y a
aussi la manière dont les élus sont
capables de continuer d'avoir une des
relations avec les avec les habitant
parce que il s'agit pas il s'agit pas de
couper le lien ça pourrait être un
risque de protection donc de s'enfermer
dans les institutions pour ne plus avoir
contact avec les habitants au contraire
mais ça ça veut dire que la vie
démocratique la vie citoyenne avec les
uns et les autres elle doit être elle
doit être garantie par la loi et ce que
le Sénat a voulu faire et que les
députés ont ont voté très récemment
c'est vraiment de rappeler le rôle
incontournable des élus dans ce pays
vous savez que quand il a fallu sortir
le pays de la crise des gilets jaunes
président de la République a eu besoin
des maires donc la contrepartie
aujourd'hui c'est de leur rendre la
possibilité d'accomplir leur mandat dans
dans la paix publique alors ce texte
augmente de 3 mois Mo à 1 an le délai de
prescription dans les affaires de
diffamation ou d'injure publique contre
un élu il y a souvent des élus qui
portent peinte contre des médias contre
des journaux sur certains articles
est-ce que c'est une atteinte à la
liberté de la presse vous lev qui est
attaché qui est attaché au liberté non
ça n'est pas une atteinte à la liberté
de la presse que de euh décaler de
quelques mois un délai un délai de
prescription ça ça me choque absolument
pas je viens de déposer plainte contre
une personne qui tous les jours publie
euh des choses me concernant j'ai saisi
le procureur de la République c'est vrai
que les délais sont extrêmement courts
si on est si on retient sur le le la
notion de diffamation si on est sur
d'autres notions de cyberhcèlement c'est
d'autres d'autres délais mais euh vous
savez euh une des choses dont on ne
parle pas dans cette affaire c'est que
beaucoup d'élus ne portent pas plainte
beaucoup d'élus vivent avec ces menaces
ces insultes et c'est cette manière de
faire donc moi j'ai j'ai toujours déposé
plainte j'ai toujours réussi à faire
condamner les personnes qui euh qui s'en
sont pris à à à moi j'ai toujours été
assez assez intransigent là-dessus il
faut aussi accompagner énormément les
élus dans leur dépôt de plainte et le
suivi des dépôt de plte et le rôle des
procureurs est un rôle énorme en la
matière c'est eux qui ont la maîtrise
des poursuites à l'égard de ceux qui
s'en prennent aux élus et c'est à eux
dans en terme de politique pénale c'est
pas tellement dans la loi ça mais
dealler très très rapidement il y a de
nombreux maires qui démissionnent face à
ces violences parfois extrêmes comment
vous faites pour éviter une crise de
l'engagement
municipal en réenchantant la démocratie
locale et en changeant la manière dont
l'état s'adresse et se comporte
vis-à-vis des élu l'état l'état exécutif
l'état
parisien la c'est 500000 élus locaux qui
se lèvent le matin pour aller s'occuper
des de leurs compatriotes il faut les
respecter ces gens-là alors on va parler
d'immigration pour finir puisque les
sénateurs centristes dont vous êtes et
les sénateurs l déposent chacun une
proposition de loi pour réintroduire les
mesures de durcissement de la loi
immigration qui avait été retoqué par le
Conseil consti
écoutez nous nous avons
repris les articles que le Conseil
constitutionnel avait jugé comme étant
des cavaliers c'est-à-dire qu'il
n'avaiit pas leur place dans le dans la
loi donc on a refait une proposition de
loi on verra le moment venu s'il a lieu
de de la sortir et de la discuter je
pense que à un moment ou un autre faudra
compléter le texte déjà voté et de notre
côté nous ne sommes pas restés les bras
ballons vous savez que à la base du
projet de loi immigration il y avait
déjà une proposition de loi portée par
les républicains par le président de la
commission des lois par François Noël
buffet et bien nous force de cette
proposition de loi qui a cette
antériorité nous allons effectivement
redéposer la proposition de loi un petit
peu modifié par rapport à ce qui a déjà
été voté et ce que nous remettrons dans
cette proposition de loi mais qui a
quand même une antériorité au regard de
ce qu'on fait les centr triste et puis
après on verra quand le texte Serar il
aura bataille de proposition de B dans
la majorité
sénateur carvé est-ce que c'est vraiment
nécessaire de remettre sur la table ce
sujet de l'immigration ah c'est pas
mettre remettre sur la table le sujet de
l'immigration le sujet de l'accueil des
des immigrés en France le sujet de la
lutte contre l'immigration clandestine
est un sujet permanent dont don dont le
Parlement doit être saisi de manière
constante il s'est trouvé que le débat a
a eu lieu dans notre pays dans des
conditions très difficiles sur un plan
politique puisque finalement le seul
débat parlementaire a eu lieu au Sénat
du fait de ce qui s'est passé à
l'Assemblée nationale avec la motion de
rejet et bien sûr puisque la motion de
rejet fait que le débat n'a pas eu lieu
et que et que par définition ce texte a
a a été mal mal construit mal vé puisque
il manque une des deux parties du du du
texte donc ça a conduit à le Conseil
cons à prendre une décision qui a écarté
des dispositions parce qu'elle n'était
pas conforme à la Constitution de
dispositions essentiellement et puis
beaucoup de dispositions parce qu'elles
étaient considérées comme cavaliers
législatif donc moi je trouve tout à
fait normal que hors sujet qui ne devait
pas être introduit dans ce texte à ce
moment-là donc c'est tout à fait normal
que les deux groupes de la majorité
sénatoriale le groupe Union centriste
auquel j'appartiens et le groupe les
républicains fort de leur sensibilité et
parfois un peu de leur différence sur le
sujet dépose ce qui leur paraît le plus
important dans ses dispositions du
Conseil écarté par le Conseil
constitutionnel et que ce débat ait lieu
il y a je vois pas pourquoi on
interdirait au Parlement de continuer de
débattre euh à ce sujet et nous on
continuera de débattre à ce sujet dans
euh le cadre de la du Sénat de la
majorité sénatoriale et évidemment du
débat démocratique qui est forcément le
nôtre débat au Sénat en tout cas le
patron des députés Renaissance à
l'assemblée a dit la semaine dernière il
était notre invité à votre place sur ce
plateau il a dit que la loi immigration
était derrière nous laissant entendre
que ces députés ne voteraient pas un
nouveau texte immigration ça veut dire
donc que ce débat n'a aucune chance
d'aboutir c'est pas le président du
groupe Renaissance à l'Assemblée
nationale qui décide de l'ordre du jour
du Parlement et encore moins d' l'ordre
du jour du Sénat donc nous sommes libres
d'une partie de notre ordre du jour
notment quand il s'agit de proposition
de loi nous discutons avec le
gouvernement et d'autant plus qu'il est
maintenant au complet sur ces sujetsl et
il y a eu quand même un deal politique
qui a été passé et qui fait que un
certain nombre de dispositions ont ont
reçu des avis favorables du gouvernement
au Sénat je m'en rappelle très bien il
se trouve que j'étais président de
séance d'une partie de ce de ce texte là
et donc des amendements qui ont été
votés avec un avis favorable du
gouvernement au Sénat doivent être des
des des des des amendements qui peuvent
faire partie du débat démocratique et on
doit continuer à aborder ces sujetslà il
y a des sujets sur lesquels pour ma part
je suis beaucoup moins à l'aise
notamment cette question de la caution
des étudiants donc je trouve très bien
que dans notre texte centriste on l'ai
pas repris c'éit c'était c'était une
aberration une idiotie de mettre ça dans
le texte pour les étudiants étrangers
les sénateurs les républicains sont
favorables à C et ben c'est leur droit
et c'est aussi notre droit d'être contre
donc dans le cadre du du du texte global
cette mesure a été a été adoptée elle a
été écartée par le Conseil
constitutionnel voilà continuons le
débat il y a aucun débat qui est
interdit et vous savez quand vous avez
l'extrême droite qui caracole en tête
des des sondages pour les élections
européennes l'idée de dire que le sujet
le sujet de migratoire n'est plus un
sujet n'est pas un sujet qu'on en
parlera plus je suis pas sûr que ce soit
un bon signal envoyer l'opinion publique
formme de la me donc à venir mais par
voie réglementaire ça c'est une bonne
chose et ça c'est une bonne chose une
manière de contourner le par non alors
ça c'est une bonne chose vous avvez deux
articles dans la Constitution l'article
34 c'est le domaine de la loi l'article
37 c'est le domaine du règlement et les
prérogatives du gouvernement c'est très
bien c'est ça Perm d'ê efficace pour oui
et c'est c'est très bien que le
gouvernement assume le fait qu'il y a
peut-être un certain nombre de choses à
régler dans laame en France donc me
l'aide médicale d'État qui permet de
soigner les étudiants les étrangers en
situation irrégulire merci d'avoir été
notre invité très bientôt ciao ciao avec
[Musique]
pl